Alright so, the, the whole goal of what we're
going to add for boosting here is we're going to, we're going to
expand on this notion of hardest examples and weighted
mean. But before I can do that, I'm going to have
to define a couple of terms. Okay. And you
let me know Michael if, if these terms make sense.
So, here's the first one. The first one is
error. So how have we been defining error so far?
>> Usually we take the square difference between the
correct labels and the, what's produced
by our classifier or regression algorithm.
>> That's true. That is how we've been using
error when we're thinking about regression error. How about, a
notion of accuracy. About how good we are at,
say, classifying examples. So let's, let's stick with classification formulas.
>> Well, that would be the same as
squared areas, except that it's not really meeting the
whole powers [INAUDIBLE] area. That is to say, if
the outputs are zeroes and ones, the squared area
is just whether or not there's a mismatch. So
it could just be the total number of wrong answers.
>> Right. So, what we've been doing so
far is counting mismatches. I like that word, mismatches.
And we might call an error raid or
an error percentage as the total number of mismatches
over the total number of examples. And that
tells us whether we're at 85% or 92%, or,
or whatever, right? So that's what we've been doing
so far. But implicit in that, Michael, is the
idea that every single example is equally as important.
So, that's not always the case. Now you might remember
from the first talk that we had. We talked
about distributions over examples. We said that, you know, learning
only happens if you're training set has the same
distribution as your future testing set. And if it doesn't,
then all bets are off. And it's very difficult
to talk about induction or learning. That notion of distribution
is implicit in everything that we've been doing so far, and
we haven't really been taking into account when we've been talking
about error. So here's another definition of error and you tell
me if you think it makes sense, given what we just
said. So, this is my definition of error. So the subscript
D, stands for distribution. So we don't know how new examples
are being drawn, but however they're being drawn they're being drawn
from some distribution, and I'm just going to call that distribution" D", okay?
>> mhm
Right. So H is our old friend the
hypothesis. That's the specific hypothesis that our learner
has output. That's what we think is the
true concept, and C is whatever the true underlying
concept is. So I'm going to define error as
the probability, given the underlined distribution that I
will disagree with the true concept on some
particular instance X. Does that make sense for you?
>> Yeah
but I'm not seeing why that's different from number of mismatches in the
sense that if we count mismatches on a sample drawn from D, which is
how we would get our testing set anyway. Then I would think that would
be you know if it's large enough a pretty good approximation of this value.
>> So here Michael, let me give you a specific example.
I'm going to draw four, four possible values of X. And when
I say I'm going to draw four possible values of X, I
mean I'm just going to put four dots on the the screen.
>> Hm.
>> Okay? And
then I'm going to tell you this particular learner output a hypothesis.
Output you know, a, a potential function that ends up getting
the first one and the third one right, but gets the
second and the fourth one wrong. So what's the error here?
>> Mm.
>> So let's just make sure that, that
everybody's with us. Let's do this as a quiz.
>> Okay, so let's ask the students what they
think. So here's the question again. You've output some hypothesis
over the four possible values of x, and it turns
out that you get the first and the third one right,
and you get the second and the fourth one wrong.
If I look at it like this, what's the error rate?